here we are going down the slide to
get from the thrilling to the mediocre
we snap share and store the memories of
our lives
by the thousands how many pictures or
videos would you say
are on your phone right now oh gosh when
i was looking the other day
for something yeah i have at least
thirteen thousand
photos on my phone and probably a few
hundred videos
and jennifer sardem who lost most of her
childhood photos in a house fire
is on a mission to archive them don't
get me rexy
for her daughter's generation and beyond
the reality is that many of the digital
possessions if you will or digital
artifacts of our life
they're not physical objects anymore
they're in the cloud
they're stored in our devices they're
contained within
other companies storage tech journalist
daniel sieberg
co-authored digital legacy a new book
that details preserving
and protecting your online afterlife
beyond
just those images it seems like such a
laborious house cleaning
task how do you figure all of that out
you know one of the challenges with
anybody's digital legacy
is that the ways in which you might wish
to manage it are not universal
what digital data do you think is
important to preserve
really everything and she's turning to
good trust
an online company that stores and
manages her cloud data
including her social media financial
documents and will
call it digital estate planning it just
feels really good and i want to be able
to
to share that and keep it alive even
long after i'm gone
because she's a veteran jennifer won't
pay for good trust's 70 dollar a year
service for a decade so we want to be a
force of good
to giving to people who served us ricar
steiber
is good trust ceo and also co-authored
digital legacy
my father passed away beginning of last
year
and then i had some good friends dying
in covid so i kind of unfortunately got
into this whole thing to sort of figure
out what happened to people's digital
accounts
when when you pass away deciding what's
worth passing on
and unlocking all of that data stored in
the cloud
is a challenge i discovered that it's
much more difficult
and you know potentially insane than
you would ever imagine consider this
there are
500 000 tweets every minute
500 million active daily users on
instagram and 1.8 billion people
active on facebook every day and that's
just the people
living i went online and i
tagged someone who's now dead and their
account was still alive
what we estimate is that on average
about 30
000 people are dying on facebook
on a daily basis and some people might
want to keep
their profiles active in some way social
media sites have varying rules for
preserving or deleting accounts
facebook allows users to appoint a
legacy contact to maintain the account
of someone
who's died and while it isn't explicitly
stated on their website
twitter does allow those with login and
password information
to continue posting on behalf of a
deceased user
in perpetuity in some cases you may be
required to have
a court order in other cases you may
need power of attorney
all the more reason says daniel seberg
to have a plan
for what makes up your physical and
digital world
we're now absolutely intertwined
between the analog physical world and
the digital virtual world
there's no going back we're all in we're
all in whether we
are absolutely comfortable with it or
ready for it or not we are now moving
into this braver new world
together and it is time for us to think
about
what anybody's digital legacy means